[Musique]
nous les gaullistes les libéraux les
démocrates chrétiens les radicaux nous
nous sommes battus pour que la
république soit la république pour que
la nation soit indépendante pour que le
peuple soit souverain et ce fut notre
grandeur depuis deux siècles nos
familles politiques ont été de toutes
les luttes de toutes les résistances qui
ont permis à la république de rester
vivante malgré les épreuves malgré les
trahisons notre vie politique ont tendu
la main à tous les combattants de la
liberté quand celle ci se trouvait
menacé du dedans et du dehors
nous qui sommes leurs héritiers
de quel droit et surtout qui pourrait
oser nous refuser le nom de républicains
qui est dans notre adn aux antilles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
je
[Musique]